pour michel polac le compte à rebours a
commencé et à quelques jours de la mise
à feu de droit de réponse l'émission qui
marque son grand retour à la télévision
michel polac un peu perdus s'aventure
dans ce qui sera bientôt le décor de
droite réponse que ça va être terminé à
temps
on a toujours peur c'est comme les
général de théâtre la veille rien n'est
prêt à 3 heures du matin celle à
laquelle affolement général puis le
rideau se lève et puis tout est en place
leur nez dans le décor balla en aidant
ce qui va être le décor c'est à dire la
f1 il y aura les passants mail de suture
à les projecteurs voilà sans suite 9 des
les micros et puis là il y aura les les
banques est on fire et les gens soient
si là ce mois ci la 3ci là bas et puis
moi je serais quelque part fait là-bas
et puis je m'adresserai aux gens qui
sont autour
puis je me lèverai de temps en temps
pour aller parler alain walo et puis un
acquis ce livre a au fond qui voudra
demandé la parole et puis
les caméras vont se promener dans ce
décor en fait voilà comment se
présentera le décor une fois terminée
une sorte de bistrot ou plutôt deux
clubs à l'anglais un lieu imaginaire si
vous voulez d'ailleurs on a tellement
d'imagination que gilles vasseur a prévu
une découverte comme ça sur un décors en
trompe l'oeil qui fait un petit peu
théâtre italien dé de la renaissance est
à son compte qu'on puisse rêver la
réalité maintenant avec le vidéographe
un étrange appareil électronique qui
permet de faire en direct des dessins à
la télévision ils étaient six data se
réaliseront un petit rôle un peu
ainsi dieu c'était parfois ils pourront
faire des petites bulles et les petits
textes sur l'écran pendant que les gens
parlent si les gens sont trop bavard ou
les ennuis ou qui sont pas d'accord ils
interviendront dans le débat mais avec
des dessins au lieu de la parole les
plus grands photographes auront
également leur mot à dire dans cette
émission qui s'organisera autour de
trois thèmes cinéma littérature est
faite société
[Musique]
et 20h30 sais pas c'est pas une heure
casse-cou pense qu'à cette heure là
c'était plutôt on avait l'habitude veut
entendre c'est là johnny hallyday eddy
mitchell
c'est très casse cou mais remarque eddy
mitchell sheila ils viendront dans
l'émission bavarder nous on passera des
goûts de disques pour discuter de leurs
chansons mais c'est vrai que c'est des
changements d'habitude mais après tout
les gens qui avaient envie de type
d'émission que nous allons faire
l'arrivée toujours attendre dix heures
du soir
maintenant ce sera eux qui vont avoir un
peu des privilèges chacun son tour c'est
normal les gens de la chanson
retrouveront leur tour plus tard il faut
faire d'alternance alors l'émission
s'appelle droit de réponse ça veut dire
que tout le monde va être un petit peu
égratignée il y aura des répercussions
des retombées oui il y aura peut-être
déjà égratignée je veux dire le problème
c'est pas des tonnes méchant
systématiquement c'est dire franchement
ce qu'on pense alors d'où la nécessité
d'un droit de réponse si quelqu'un dit
quelque chose de discutable il faut
toujours que la réponse soit possible
même au téléphone avec as bp s'il le
faut voir svp sur le plateau et il y
aura affiché la semaine suivante devenir
aussi avec nous discuter dire non je
suis pas d'accord ce qu'on a dit la
semaine dernière un invité sur ce
plateau michel polac michel polac de
retour à la télévision après dix années
d'absence pour une émission du samedi
soir à 20h30 sur tf1 samedi demain
demain la première mon droit de réponse
ben c'est à dire que nous avons essayé
de refaire une émission un peu dans le
style de post scriptum il ya dix ans
mais à 20h30 qui tout de même c'est une
heure plus tôt des variétés mais pas
peur qu'elle soit aussi controversé que
l'ancien s'il y aura certainement des
controverses
d'ailleurs il ya des sujets ces
polémiques dans l'âme dès la première
mais si vous voulez l'important c'est
qu'à 20h30 il faut quand même s'adresser
à un public beaucoup plus vaste que des
émissions culturelles qu'on fait
d'habitude à 23h et donc nous avons sa
poudre l émission d'humour de dessin
des caricaturistes ils font des dessins
en direct des extraits de films et de
choses comme ça
c'est à dire que vous allez éliminer les
chanteurs on a l'habitude la deuxième
émission à seulement elle va nous parler
des films qu'elle a vu dans la semaine
par exemple ce qu'il ne fait pas
d'habitude elle chante d'habitude
là elle va chanter un petit peu aussi
seul que la course avait quarante
invités demain soir c'est vraiment super
production c'est la super production
mais vous savez 40 a vite ils parleront
pathos et pour me soutenir ce sont des
amis ce sont des journalistes que j'aime
bien ce sont des invités qui reviendront
souvent dans l'émission qui donc
pourront poser des questions et puis
revenir d'autrefois certain nombre de
constantes parlait mais ils me font
confiance j'espère par une émission et
lithiques alors quel genre un peu club
tout de même j'espère que non je
voudrais que tout le monde puisse la
suivent parce qu'on savait si gérard de
villiers vient demain gérard depardieu
vient je crois pas que ce soit des gens
qui soient particulièrement élitiste sad
il ya aussi des gars morin qui est un
philosophe très sérieux qui j'espère
pourra et jordanienne qui parlera de son
journal c'est un mélange et j'espère que
justement grâce à ce mélange on pourra
s'aperçoit que les français peuvent
communiquer entre eux ce qui leur manque
un petit peu
en gros pas de culture ennuyeuse surtout
pas michel bonne chance pour demain soir
merci
[Musique]
mais
m
bonsoir et bien au sommaire ce soir
gérard depardieu vous ne reconnaissez
pas c'est coluche
invité surprise de dernière minute sans
ptr bretécher gérard de villiers
jean daniel olivier toth edgar morin
jacques laurent kavanagh roger
knobelspiess nadine joly commissaire de
police
j'en perds une claude roy cabu et siné
qui vont dessiner ce soir et des
documents sur bernard lavilliers ariane
mnouchkine est naturellement tous les
invités qui sont sur ce plateau je ne
peux pas les nommer tous mais il y a
beaucoup d'amis de téléspectateurs de
journalistes qui viennent à notre
émission qui reviendront souvent alors
je les nommerai en cours de huit
démission et naturellement ils pourront
parler quand ils le voudront
il leur présente différentes tendances
de plusieurs journaux et il pose des
questions quand ils veulent poser des
questions il y a aussi tous les
téléspectateurs qui peuvent nous
téléphoner vous connaissez je pense
numéro cs bp 11 11
les téléspectateurs de paris comme de
province peuvent appeler si les sujets
les concernent directement et si ils
estiment qu'ils ont un droit de réponse
possible sur un sujet s'il se sentent
vraiment concernés ne nous pose pas des
questions sur n'importe quoi nous
serions vite submergé vous avez vu dans
cette émission générique qui a été
réalisé grâce à un prototype français
ça s'appelle la paluche est un objet
tout à fait étrange vous le voyez alors
petit cocorico comme fait qu'à but
derrière moi oui c'est ça youpla
cocorico le cocorico français à la mode
en ce moment mais enfin qu'est ce que
vous voulez c'est une invention
française de même que cet appareil assez
bizarre qui est un prototype lui aussi
que nous utilisons pour la première fois
à la télévision avec lequel cabu et
ciney vont pouvoir faire des dessins en
direct c'est-à-dire commenter les propos
de
nos invités et dire tout ce qui leur
passe par la tête
alors ces deux objets ont été fabriqués
à grenoble le bravo pour la ville de
grenoble et il y aura un troisième
gadgets électroniques dans l'émission à
partir du mois de janvier
il s'agit du thé lady du vidéo disque
français nous allons faire une grande
première mondiale c'est toutes les
couvertures disponible de l'édition
française seront mis son vidéo disque il
nous suffira d'appuyer sur un bouton et
à la salle instant même dans une scène
une seconde vous verrez apparaître le
livre dont nous parlerons dans
l'émission je crois que ce sera très
utile pour évoquer comme ça mais ton des
classiques des livres qui une citation
que l'un d'entre vous voudra faire
immédiatement l'auteur apparaître à
faire la couverture du livre de l'auteur
à paraître bon avant de jouer abandonné
un petit peu les gadgets et pour
commencer l'émission tout de même je
voudrais pour situer un petit peu car
nous sommes à 20h30 ce qui est un peu
insolite je crois qu'à svp il ya déjà
des appels sur ce problème nous allons
montrer un dessin de sempé art qui peut
être pourrait situer à c'est bien là le
propos est la situation où nous nous
trouvons alors voilà ce dessin de sempé
qui a quelques années vous devez le
connaître
rayon loi allez-y coluche alors alors
chers amis maintenant je voudrais vous
poser la question que doivent se poser
tout noté spectateurs comment votre
concept onirique à tendance kafkaïenne
qu'en est il avec la vision sub logique
que vous faites de résistance
intrinsèque sauvé voilà sans paix il ya
combien de temps j'ai fait ce dessin pas
mal de temps ça concernait quelle
émission et 26 ans donc vous visiez
personnes n'ont en tout cas vous aviez
un certain a tendance à vous moquer des
émissions qui emploie un langage un
petit peu abstrait bon je pense qu'à
l'époque j'ai souvent pensé à lecture
pour tous la wii et vous vous disiez
qu'évidemment dans certaines fermes de
la lozère on devait être un peu surpris
parfois par certains invités bon c'est
un peu un manquement dans les fermes et
lozère non non non on devrait même d'un
certain
je crois que si j'ai pour présenter ce
dessin c'est parce qu'effectivement à
20h30 depuis une vingtaine d'années les
téléspectateurs sont habitués à voir des
variétés bondir que notre émission d'une
émission de variétés ce serait tout de
même mentir disons un on ne sait jamais
gérard bon on a déjà on a déjà un
chanteur justement je voulais dire qu'il
y aurait des chanteurs dans l'émission
il y aura gérard depardieu y aura il y
aura celle à la semaine prochaine parce
que nous ne sommes pas sectaires moi un
jeu sexuel a pas que moi
cette semaine elle a pas pu parce
qu'elles savaient qu'ils avaient connue
chez cet été qui chantait trop bien
keller est trop de concurrence enfin
mettons que nous voulons mettre un petit
peu de variété dans les émissions à
défaut d'être une émission de variétés
nous ne sommes pas non plus qu'on
pourrait appeler une émission culturelle
parce que vous savez que le mot culture
lorsqu'on emploie
goering sortait son revolver le
téléspectateur d'après les sondages lui
l'appui sur l'autre bouton ruches
avaient même l'expression encore plus
qu'est ce que tu as fait ce qu'il a dit
alors j'ai oublié j'ai dit si c'est
culturel
on se tire nous ah oui goering
tirez-vous voulu tirer et 7,7 et
goebbels
il me semblait aussi toute façon des
rings aurait dit la même chose
cette pierre desproges père des proches
de moi bien aussi parce que c'est le
couple en jaune à paris quelques minutes
avait dit que les invitera ensemble
c'était pas vrai mais pierre desproges
manuel de savoir vivre à l'usagé des
rustres des malpolis c'est encore un
coup dur maintenant je fais de la pub
pour cette collection je voulais faire
ça c'est le même que la mie câline zhai
zhenwu et bien tant pis il se trouve
qu'ils ont pu passer un bon éditeur rien
de sa collection point virgule cdu poche
manuel de savoir-vivre et autres
reprises nous ça nous fait beaucoup rire
si j'aime folie était pas brouiller avec
moi depuis samedi dernier elles ont
presque à la fin papier de verre et
c'est par coeur de nyala dit des choses
justes les mettons tous les livres de
pierre desproges parker bah oui il ne
faudrait pas répéter mon édition pierre
ça me donnerait nous arrive un petit
bout oui tu verras bien ventes que pour
ça je viens vous en parle pas de cul on
parle de qu'on sait c'est vraiment un
vrai manuel sourire à lisier il s'agit
là dans ce chapitre qui très intéressant
de reconnaître les cons oui alors
existe-t-il des signes extérieurs de
conneries oui on peut reconnaître un con
rien qu'à sa façon de s'habiller
la caractéristique vestimentaire du
conte consiste en a besoin irrésistible
de s'habiller comme tout le monde
faites le test suivant les enfants aux
yeux je m'étais dit personnes dans une
pièce observez bien ces dix personnes
sur ces 10 personnes il y en a au moins
une qui est habillé comme les neuf
autres c'est un con ces scientifiques
quand 40 personnes s'habille comme un
con c'est l'académie française
vous êtes en mille personnes s'habille
comme un con c'est l'armée française
nous l'armée soviétique apport moyen en
a une que j'aimais beaucoup mais je
voulais pas me la lyre et maintenant
cette star oui c'est elle la lettre
trésor public mon cher 13 heures c'était
vraiment été bien présente un journal
qui à mon avis doit croire à certaines
valeurs qu'elle charlie hebdo n'a jamais
cru jean bourdier de minutes
en effet votre réactiver votre réaction
sur ce journal et sur sa mort oui les
tours de partie parce que je suis
toujours désolé de voir crever un
journal parce que j'en ai vu trop crevé
et qu'il n'était pas en place et alors
quand je parle dans les laisser parler
ni se parler ce taux de banat par l'apel
minutes très bruns bon eh bien tant
mieux chez ravi parce que vous amener
mon deuxième propos qui va venir en son
temps je précise que quand je parle de
journal je ne parle pas du bulletin
d'information l'ambassade de lure chez
nommé l'humanité je parle d'un vrai
journal
bon charlie hebdo était bas
personnellement je trouvais pour sa
follement drôle je n'étais pas du tout
client même pas regardeur sauf pour le
fameux bal trajet tragique à colombey un
mort
et qui m'a beaucoup amusé dans ton qu'il
aura valu des minus [ __ ]
non non mon ciné 12 en paix alors si
l'incident nous allons nous avons ici la
démonstration du comportement des gens
qui sont pour la liberté d'esprit tout
je ne suis pas par la liberté d'esprit
en une et c'est finir laisser finir en
ordre n'entendez chou demande un peu de
silence entre minuk normal mais vivant
vous faire croire alors écouté et je
peux pas rouler roulent encore parce que
c'est tout le monde le veut je vous
demande de me laisser faire cette
émission je fais les missions vous
n'êtes pas l'avenir des jets à les
minuteries seront je suis déjà bien je
rentre vite que minutes existe un g8
existent sont venus je revendique le
hara-kiri existe non écoutés pour
l'instant le bourbier n'a rien pu dire
alors laissez le terminer parce que la
démocratie cdc chacun parlait alors ému
jean bourdier on thon rouge jean
bourdier laisser parler en bourbier
alors je regrette le voir périr un
journal je suis contraint de me répéter
puisque il ya quelques interruptions
chanteur silence et
[Musique]
non écouter respecter un minimum de
règles du jeu sens à cette émission
offre à la fois qu'on ne peut pas la
faire
alors que jean wauthier albert moi je
suis disposé à m'engager sur mais dans
la barre au final c'est tout parce que
je regrette j'ai entendu des propos vous
somme des incompris et quand un journal
disparaît il y d'abord incompris de ses
lecteurs c'est tout le monde a reconnu
mais au lieu de se demander pourquoi on
est incompris de ses lecteurs j'ai vu
des gens qui en gueul est les gens qui
ne les visaient pas pourquoi ça je ne
comprends pas je ne comprends pas
l'attitude de l'équipe de charlie hebdo
allégations d'excès un pénis et 1,10 m
bon on le lit peut on ne lit pas du tout
voilà nos raisons au lieu de les écouter
et de respecter leur opinion après tous
ces grands partisans de la liberté
d'opinion les engueuler moi je ne
comprends pas cette attitude
et quand mon journal se vendra plus je
veux dire est que c'est moi qui suis en
tort et pas les lecteurs que j'aurais pu
avoir c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire bon
merci jean bourdier réponse de kavanagh
c'est exactement ce que j'ai dit c'est
exactement si vous deviez si on n'était
plus lui c'est qu'on se plaisait plus
solidaire et qui
au total on a évoqué mais je prends pas
avec la même équipe et s'endort métro 10
ans je n'ai pas bien sûr c'est ça qui
vient tout à fait inadmissible que les
fachos alors écoutez bon écoutez on va
vous calmer tous un petit peu on va vous
envoyer à dessin animé de mordille on
sait absolument charmant on va se calmer
un instant alors cordillot noah - des
bons est-ce qu'on peut envoyer ce dessin
animé de mort dit aux histoires de se
calmer je voudrais bien qu'on respecte
une règle du jeu
et pour ça il faudrait peut-être un
petit peu d'ordre sur le plateau parce
que on peut pas trop
ils sont passés à lola temps tout à
l'heure bon jeu tout con secondes et on
est quand même un coup derrière ce que
je peux répondre à ces assises
ainsi défection aura les taureaux un mot
bon je dis je dis que c'est ce que c'est
qui ce jour là lors rien à dire
pourquoi qui les invite en fait non
seulement la droite par les mêmes ceux
qui n'ont rien à dire pourquoi ils tuent
invite des lycéens ne veut rien dire
la fosep ça ne veut plus rien dire
lyciens cdmr 2 est frustré des
convertisseurs on a les écoutes
excuse moi j'espère que caméra est sur
moi polak je vous dire que ce que je
viens d'entendre dire là c'est rien du
tout c'est les moues de ma mère c'est
des mots de ma grand-mère chérie moore
imprimés qu'on leur a mis dans la tête
ils n'ont rien dire ces jeunes qu'on l'a
efforts moi d'y aller pas de quoi il a
droit
ils n'ont rien à [ __ ] bon ça nous
fichons ce sont ce sont des petits than
qu'on nourrit c'est très bien et qui
ferment leur gueule
merci sans un retour sur l'actualité
d'hier soir cela se passait sur tf1 à
l'antenne l'émission droit de réponse
michel polac dirige les débats s'il vous
plaît des f-15 en ce sens que deux
minutes et râle a dit que j'étais que je
me suis dégonflé à strasbourg
ce qui est absolument de lattes et la
scion car j'ai mis les parents d'un
[Musique]
jeune enfant la can et là bas la preuve
télégénique
[Musique]
merde alors
nous allons passer un peu de musique à
réquista franchement aller un petit peu
de silence le voudraient n'auraient
cutter ou à ma charge dans ce cas je
crois dire à la vue mouchon comme signer
comme elycia je crois certaines valeurs
universelles une valeur et je vois c'est
qu'on croit rêver les chiens confusion
la parole à ckoi jamais alou merde
voulons nous les damnés de la terre on a
le droit de jacques t on vous en mer et
on emmerde jamais en mer de bonne humeur
minutes a dit mme allard qui essaye de
tout ce qui se dit je voudrais signaler
que sur ce plateau ce soir sont venues
des invités qui ont chacun le droit
d'amener un invité qui se teignent est
assis dans le fond de la salle j'aurais
voulu que ces gens respectent un peu
l'émission autrement nous inviterons
plus les gens que sur l'émission mais ça
ça m'est égal vous aimerez ce métier pas
comment vous vous taisez voilà alors je
voudrais quand même pas je savais que
madame molinier qui est venu là soir
elle va finir par le regretter
parce que non mais je vous comprends
bien je n'ai pas de chance évidente on
arrières audy à chaque émission alors si
laure dufresnes voilà c'est ce qu'on dit
à chaque échange mentionné mois on
pourrait peut-être dire des choses
concrètes et on va demander à lyon c'est
vrai mais je pense que le fond du
pruneau show biz malléole essor
médecin alors nous allons y je regrette
que les laitages cm amener des éleveurs
et je vais vous faire écouter en saurait
plus et assume cette chanson voilà
regarde les cellules à envoyer générique
de fin et couper l'image parce que c'est
vraiment pas plaisant
mettez le le générique de fin avec la
chanson devient colombo voilà mettez la
chanson devient colombo et me fait
l'antenne en conflent ted et je m'excuse
mais les téléspectateurs
toi qui me
arrêté en même temps
de blanche
[Musique]
on ne va pas attendre plus longtemps on
va demander aux professeurs pierre
desproges ce qu'il pense du sportif
oui en fait j'ai dressé un portrait
psychosomatiques du sportif commun alors
tout d'abord on peut dire qu'on divise
les sportifs en trois grandes catégories
les mâles les femelles et les nageuses
au stade monde reprend venir directement
au mode de vie du sportif commun comme
l'homme le sportif est un mammifère il
se reproduit donc comme l'homme quand le
sportif sans monter en lui l'appel
irrésistible du désir c'est plus fort
que lui il faut qu'il aille au stade
alors il va au stade et ça passe moins
imaginative la femme du sportif sentant
grandir en elle l'appelle du désir va
aux coiffeurs et non pas chez le
coiffeur où ils risqueraient de
rencontrer la coiffeuse des cieux on
dénombre en france cinq grandes espèces
de sportif le cycliste d'abord qui est
très importante
le civiliste moyen est viscéralement
sous doués d'ailleurs il a la tête plus
bas que le cul surtout dans les côtes
on peut l'observer assez facilement au
lit comme à bicyclette la
caractéristique du cycliste et qu'il
espère faire mieux la prochaine fois
le cycliste à une seconde peau qui
s'appelle le maillot jaune c'est un
simple maillot de type jean-edern
hallier c'est à dire que on le voit très
bien l'image même de très loin et qui
s'enlève tout seul
le tennis aussi d'autre part le tennis
est un sport noble mais ennuyeux comme
on a pu en juger
récemment en écoutant le commentaire
radiophonique de la finale de roland
garros
ces villas skipass haviland air qui
passe à villa ce qui façonne voilà c'est
un peu chiant
la boxe maintenant pour ce monsieur et
demi sur le plateau on a beaucoup mais
10 de la boxe on a même prétendu que les
anciens boxeurs à la retraite devenaient
de véritables épaves humaine
c'est complètement faux il existe des
anciens boxeurs heureux il laisse
tranquillement pif le chien en braille
et tout va mieux pour eux alphonse
halimi réagir les courses je ne reviens
que tout ambiancé blanc et gentil pour
changer avant l'époque pour changer
venons en aux courses qui sont le sport
le plus distingué en france les
hippodromes d'ailleurs sont plaints de
bi gomme et jay baronne en perd deux et
qui regardent des nains bariolés filets
des coupes de pompe dans le bide à des
canassons lanceur qui leur ont rien fait
c'est baronne achètent leurs perles avec
l'argent des allocations familiales que
les
tonio vienne claqué aux courses c'est le
sport national français
le football maintenant bien que
l'essentiel de son savoir-faire se situe
au niveau de ses pieds le footballeur
est également fort bien musclé du haut
on cite notamment le cas du footballeur
platini dans le tour de poitrine atteint
118 cm 108 cm entre le 1er et le 2ème ot
de marlborough et un drôle de regard des
sportifs claudio un ouais ouais
pour finir il ya une question que l'on
peut se poser y at il une intelligence
du sportif oui il de rythme elle est
sensiblement d'ailleurs la même chez le
footballeur le tennisman le jockey le
cheval ou le boxeur le quotient
intellectuel du sportif moyens et voisin
de celui de l'autre russe d'ailleurs si
l'autriche baisse la tête c'est pas du
tout pour se l'offrir dans le sable
c'est pour avoir l'air d'un coureur
c'est bien connu
pour finir un chiffre le record mondial
du plus bas quotient intellectuel c'est
un sportif est détenu actuellement par
le soviétique youri korsakov
c'est lui qui a tenté en vain d'ailleurs
d'imposer aux derniers jeux olympiques
le lancement du poing sur glace